l'europe doit devenir à nouveau une
puissance il n'y a pas de puissance
possible sans avoir un maîtrise de ses
moyens économiques
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
rétablir une préférence communautaire et
réserver 50 % des marchés aux
entreprises locales il importe également
que l'on respecte la règle de la
réciprocité
les marchés européens ne doit pas être
ouvert sans qu'il y ait l'exigence du
respect réciprocité c'est à dire que les
pays qui veulent exporter chez nous
doivent pouvoir être soumis au droit
européen
à voir également le la possibilité de
d'être négligé de leur part qu'ils
respectent les normes européennes en
matière d'environnement ou en matière de
travail des enfants
il importe aussi que l'on puisse lutter
contre la concurrence déloyale avec le
dumping social qu'il faut combattre
particulièrement matière de travailleurs
détachés lesquels doivent pouvoir être
soumis aux cotisations du pays dans
lequel ils travaillent enfin il faut
défendre la politique agricole et
particulièrement le budget puisque c'est
la clé même de notre autonomie
alimentaire et cet objectif d'être
prioritaires l'europe ne sera une
puissance qu'est ce qu'elle filtre
également les investissements étrangers
et qu'elles réservent les secteurs
stratégiques aux entreprises européennes
pour lutter contre les grands groupes
mondiaux